[Music]
hello I'm Julian so today I'm going to
talk about from flat files to
deconstructed database so a little bit
about me I'm a principal engineer at we
work one of the co-creators of parquet
have been involved with Apache project
for a while I got my first commuter ship
on the Apache big project to use big
yeah and I use Hadoop first at Yahoo in
2007
yeah mole and formally I was at Twitter
working on data platform I work at
dreamy Oh and there was a presentation
from Dromio today working on query
engine stuff also I forgot I'm also this
is a King Julien from Madagascar who's
as the same first name as me so if you
know I'm doing like King Julien so
here's the agenda the roughly how we go
over that talk so first I'm going to
talk about Hadoop you know at the
beginning there was a dupe created in
2005 but actually you know you know this
guy
this is Michael Stonebraker I'm Turing
Award winner Michael Stonebraker so is
one of the legend of the database
research famous for ingress buzz grace
and more central Vertica and what we
technically call not a bozo
and really I really didn't like
MapReduce at the beginning and I'll go
over why and I'll finish with what the
deconstructed database is so this is a
picture of a deconstructed bento box and
so you can see you of your Maki except
you have all the ingredients separated
and you make whatever you want with it
so at the beginning there was a dude
this is a picture of the original Hadoop
toy that the Hadoop project is named
after by docketing
so Hadoop is based on a couple of Google
papers the MapReduce paper and the GFS
paper so those are the two main
abstractions that you can build with the
distributed file system which is
basically unlimited storage for whatever
you want and the MapReduce which is kind
of the limited processes or you know
scales you can throw more machines at it
for processing those files and that the
basic idea behind Hadoop and there's a
lot you can do with this yeah Hadoop is
great for looking for a needle in a
haystack with no pose it's kind of
especially at the time it's kind of a
blunt tool right you're just like oh
let's flows through all of this through
a lot of machines of this and and you
know when you can and you can scale
stuff use a lot of horsepower and you do
it but it's kind of blunt especially at
the beginning so the main abstraction
where I talked about the storage in the
execution and they're good thing about
it and they're bad things about it you
know the storage is just flat files your
files in any binary any schema no
standard and basically the job must know
how to split the data how to make it
like parallel processing an execution is
simple it's flexible it's composable
right you can do multiple MapReduce jobs
that do different things and it's all
based on we are going to run the mappers
locally close to the data so you know
you can very quickly load and process
the data then there's the shuffle
mechanism to reorganize the data around
keys right you output key values and
you're going to put all the values for
the same key on the same machine and
again you can process them together and
write locally and the shuffle is usually
the bottleneck park of the of the
process but if you do your mappers write
your registers right you can do a lot of
processing and it's there are a lot of
operations that
map in this or you can use a multiple
MapReduce job to implement and another
aspect yeah so it dies execution with
persistence you know it kind of old
cobbled together but if you want just to
hack something is really good so now we
get back to Michael Stonebraker Turing
Award winner Michael Stonebraker in 2015
and just like so you know Map Reduce was
becoming very very popular everybody was
talking about it that was the best thing
since sliced bread so it's kind of like
say like hey guys let's look a little
bit about what we've been doing in
database research for the past decades
right so the relational model was first
described in 1969 and sequel was created
in 70's by IBM in 86 it the first sunk
standard was described and it's been a
dated you know you see all like from 89
to 2016 it's been updated many times and
over just all that period of time it's
also became a standard like everybody
knows I understand sequel can took
sequel so like it's a base to a lot of
tools so if you're not using sequel if
you're not taking advantage of that
you're losing a lot and there's also a
bunch of good properties which
Stonebraker argued in is blog post at
the time so first when you write sequel
you define the logic of your application
you focus exclusively on what you want
and all the details about how it's
stored how it's indexed how you optimize
this process all that is separated in a
common implementation right so you can
have all your logic you have clean
sequel queries that hopefully it's very
clear what you're trying to achieve and
you don't mix together all the objects
Asian all the details on how you store
the data how you do like smart algorithm
to make it go fast all that is separated
from your logic in reusable another
aspect is integrity in sequel you put
into
he constrains right you can define how
your data is updated so that you don't
get inconsistent data whether it's for
referential integrity or generally your
data respecting some constraints and you
have things like schemas and views to
deal with evolution half the diffusion
of your data and of course it's a
standard it's been around for a while
and you know you'd benefit from the
entire ecosystem and so if we compare
the abstraction so remember in Hadoop
you have file system and MapReduce and
in a relational database the storage is
abstracted under a notion of table so a
table as a schema and you focus more on
the logical aspect of it and it
abstracts out how it's stored the layout
indices statistics and the execution
part is abstracted being sequel right
and again you kind of decouple the whole
logic of how the data is stored and all
the optimization and what's the best
joint to use on what order to do the
joints of should we filter before we
join in all those kind of concerns you
decouple that from defining the logic of
what you want and if we dig a little
deeper right so when the you know you
have this picture you have sequel and
then they're multiple steps on how it
gets executed and how you get to this
efficient processing right you issue the
sequel and the database rich on the
answer hopefully quickly so steps first
you start with parsing the sequel the
syntax and then semantic is about making
sense of all this name is actually a
table it has a schema so if because this
table has a schema you can refer to the
field that's part of that schema so that
the semantic aspect and then there's
optimization step that's going to decide
what order do we execute the joints in
should we push the features first in the
scan and all those things and then you
actually execute it and so you it's all
works well it's a very well integrated
system right the optimization rules
really are closely coupled with how the
execution is going to use them right so
look what's the best join so you have
this notion of cost based optimization
of like using this type of join include
as this cost based on the size of the
data and this also type of Jonah is a
different cost and we can combine a lot
of different parameters together to try
to find the best most efficient fastest
plan for executing the query so if you
look at how it works
right first you parse the syntax of your
sequel query you get like a tree syntax
tree that represents it next step is you
get the schema potentially statistics
from your data from your data is there
any index is it sorted a lot of
information and you fit that into the
optimizer that will speed up the
execution plan and then once you have
your plan you run it on your database so
here I'm kind of drawing a distributed
type of database like you know similar
to Vertica or redshift all those those
MPP databases which usually there's your
data is stored in in columnar format you
have push downs to make it efficient to
project retrieve the data from disk and
then you know there's some kind of
execution engine and eventually to
delegates to the user and so you have
this tight integration in the optimizer
knows exactly how the execution works to
get the best plan for execution so
that's well integrated and that's how
it's fast so yeah I mean Michael
Stonebraker makes a point right so why
did we go back to flat files and
whatever craziness Hadoop is it's just
like like going with snow plows instead
of that so ligant tool that we have with
sequel so there's some reason write
sequel there are a lot of constraints
baked into sequel and constraints are
good because constrain
I want hello for all those optimizations
right because we have this notion of
table and you know it has to look like
it has a schema and it's abstract stood
out and sequel and we fully understand
what sequel is right so we have a sequel
query when the optimizer knows exactly
everything that's had happening and like
Hadoop when you run code it's kind of
opaque right you have byte code or
whatever language you're using is
completely opaque to the framework so it
can't really optimize how you access
data whatever you do so in sequel you
have a bunch of constraints how you
access data how you define your logic
and it's good because that's what
enables the optimizer to do a lot of
things and make it fast and all those
things but at the same time you know
there are a lot of use cases that don't
fit that well in those abstractions and
so those constraints it's important to
have the right set of constraints and in
particular databases don't have those
all right it's not in that standard of
having those lower level abstractions
right it's kind of especially at the
time like flat schemas in flexible
schema evolution like everything in the
table as to have the same schemas and
when you're changing things makes it
harder you always have to fix you old
data to make it fit with the new schema
here there's a lack of lower level
abstraction to access to the data in a
less relational way and those integrity
constraints we talked about are not
always very scalable when you start
having like a distributed database so
there's a lot of constraint that didn't
fit quite well so constraints are good
and what's enable very good
implementation but you you know as the
world evolves we need to evolve those
constraints and so that's the beauty of
a doob like Hadoop is there's no data
shape constraints so you can experiment
where you can do graph data structure
nested data structure and structure
texts with semantics and notation like
like an Hadoop came from the
indexing the world for search engine
non-uniform schemas you can do whatever
you want and it's just code right so
there's room to scale a lot of different
algorithms you're not constrained by
implementing it in sequel you can
implement in in different languages you
can do it if stuff you can do a lot of
different things and so that's a lot
more flexible and a lot of machine
learning logic works on top of Hadoop
and it's a lot harder to think about it
in terms of sequel yeah so there's and
there's a beauty of open source right so
you can take a do you can fork it you
can take components and all those things
that exist in the a dupe ecosystem you
can reuse them you can reuse a component
with something else you can there's a
lot more room to innovate
if you look at no Oracle you cannot take
it apart and do things with it or even
Vertica you cannot take it apart and do
things like Postgres you do and a lot of
people have used for various parts of
Postgres to you like Fred shift is based
on Postgres a lot of things are and so
there's this there's a lot of things
that I can happen from that right so
Hadoop is flexible so flexible and
composable that you can actually
implement sequel with this right and
they did I'm sure a lot of you have used
hive and when hive starting right like
you kind of skip the optimizer part and
you just you parse the sequel you
produce a plan and you kind of run it as
a sequence of MapReduce jobs right so
you can do your filter with the
MapReduce you join with the MapReduce
job you could buy and you throw you know
it's composable snow blows you so snow
flows after snow clothes and it's great
so that's the original hive I know that
I see people who have been making high
faster in the room so that's the
original hive it's not been working like
that for a while open source in 2009 so
that was just after Mike Stone breakers
blog post and so if we look 10 years
later
this all has changed a lot all right
that's where we get to my deconstructed
database image right so you have all the
ingredients and you cannot recompose
them in the way you want and if you were
an engineer so this is a deconstructed
typewriter and so you take a typewriter
take it apart and then you can recompose
components right so it's kind of look at
those database components and you have
the query model the data exchange batch
execution storage layer and you end up
with a lot of different components by
the way this is not an exhaustive
picture just throw and is focusing on
open source components really but there
are lots of different things and don't
try to read it all it's just like in
your face like a lot of projects are
collaborating in that space and they're
all that kind of compose off of each
other in some way and so you can mix and
match all those components there's
storage there's query model you have a
lot of machine learning components that
don't really fit in the traditional
database model data exchange batch and
streaming execution you start seeing
batch and streaming sequel happening and
all those things and they reuse similar
components then we can do different
things and as part of this like mess of
all different components all different
competing projects you can see some
standard components emerging and I'm
going to talk about those a little bit
some of the key things
there's columnar storage and so
obviously park' is one of those and park
it being more like columnar at rest like
today most of those projects can read or
write park a sequel engine can read and
write
Parkay so it's that aspect like if we
look at vertical if we look at all those
columnar MPP databases
like the lowest layer right how do you
lay out the data so you can access it
quickly sequel parsing and optimization
so this optimizer step one of the you
know maybe less known and most used
component of the Hadoop ecosystem is
calcite and I'll have a slab to dig into
that right after a calcite is this
optimizer that knows how to use a cost
model to get the best plan there's
schema model the Avro is one of those
becoming the standard for defining
schema in the Big Data world columnar
exchange arrow become the kind of
interoperable efficient format for
exchanging data between all those
systems and I think in the table
abstraction I put like more like a
challenger like Netflix iceberg is
interesting in my opinion it's more like
a new thing and it's kind of this is the
area where we don't have a standard yet
or I mean there are standards but it's
kind of just been there from the
beginning but I think we need to improve
in that area so if you think about CAD
site what is calcite so if you look at
you know I had this four step how the
sequel processing happen from syntax
semantics optimization execution so
calcite is all the first part tex equal
n so calcite as the parser you know it's
like your front end in order to parse
equal represent it as a model and then
you can provide plugins on how you're
going to expose your schemas and I'm
simplifying a bit because there's a lot
of things you can plug into CAD site so
on purpose I'm making like a simpler use
case when you have plugins for schemas
and you can plug-in optimizer rules that
depend on your execution engine and you
provide that calcite and it has all the
dynamic programming logic of a
cost-based optimizer to provide to you
the best plan right so how you
manipulate this data how you normalize
it and how you provide the best plan and
you can provide your own execution
engine and cal sign has its own little
execution built-in but usually I'm
thinking in terms of distributed
execution and Julian hide right here in
the room so if you have question has
came instead because you know a lot more
than I do
so you can imagine you have all those
storage things and you can have a little
plugins and you can have optimizer rules
that are either specific to the storage
layer or specific to the execution layer
and you know that's that powers a lot of
different projects so to give you an
idea and I'm sure this is not exhaustive
but today calcite is used as the
optimizer in hive in Apache drill in
Phoenix Phoenix being sequel on top of
HBase in Kylene which is a cube engine
and there are also a bunch of streaming
sequel engine which is like more
real-time dashboard producing using
sequel like apache apex flink and
there's a Samsung sequel and storm
sequel that use calcite so just like
it's used everywhere it is really one of
those standard components if you think
of the storage layer so there are two
key components you know there's like the
immutable aspect which is more like for
analysis you store data over time and
then the mutable storage layers and they
all will have like some important
characteristics they share to make
efficient query processing on top of
them so I'm going to summarize it
looking at the push downs right so
that's what we are referred to as push
downs and let this common interface
layer for storage from analytics
perspective right how do we access this
data efficiently so in the query you
will have a filter you will access only
a subset of the columns and possibly do
aggregations so a lot of those things
you want to do as close to the storage
layer as you can and so that's where
columnar representation the columnar
layout helps with projection so
projection is accessing only the columns
you want predicates pushdowns
is about using at the same time the
layout may be the data is partition
maybe the data is sorted and then you
can use that to scan only the parts that
match your filters or maybe the data has
statistics and so something can skips
part of it based on the filter and be
much more efficient at accessing the
data you want an aggregation
similarly once you accessed only the
columns you want only the rows you want
and you're performing aggregation to
avoid materializing this intermediary
data and sending it to the query engine
you can start aggregating just in right
there as you're reading the data you can
start summing for example and add all
those values and you've written just
this instead of returning the entire
data you scan and summing it up later
so all those those are like the key
three things you want in a storage layer
to make it really efficient at querying
and a lot of those support that and you
see like having that that's part of that
key storage component whether it's
mutable or immutable
having those properties is very
interesting so if we look at the bigger
picture of how things interact
right this is an example of how query
execution works so on the previous slide
I was focusing on the optimizer and
that's the execution how we do do we do
distributed execution of a query so if
we take a simple query as doing an
aggregation with a Sun you see on the
right you know you pass it to calcite
calcite produce the plan and we imagine
that we have three nodes on that cluster
in a scanner
we catch that we have pushdowns the
filters the projection as low as
possible so that we read as little data
from disk as possible an arrow is this
in-memory columnar representation that
combines three properties the first is
to be an efficient format for query
processing in
Murray writes columnar so you can do
very efficient vectorized execution
second it's the way it's laid out make
it serialization free so there's no
overhead in copying it from memory to
the network back to memory because the
representation in memory is exactly the
same than on the wire unlike things like
Avro or other you know like anything
that builds objects in memory you would
end up doing a lot of lookups a lot of
small allocations in memory and a lot of
like writing play in random places in
memory that make it really inefficient
for salvation dissertation or for memory
access from a query engine perspective
and that's looked all looking at this
from the core engine perspective so
columnar presentation then can be
serialized sent to the network without
any serialization cost is very efficient
and the third property is it being
standard right so that you can exchange
data without having to worry about using
the lowest common denominator between
system whether it's like pickle or JSON
or CSV all the things that are very not
efficient and so that's where arrow fits
in being really good as the a memory
representation for execution and as an
exchange format so just a quick stop on
the stream persistence layer and so like
everybody knows about Kafka pulsar is
another interesting project that calf
has a lot more adaption than pulsar but
I think pulsar has a lot of interesting
characteristics so I invite you to go
take a look and there you know if you
think of that projection push down
notion a lot of those things for at rest
storage for batch annalistic or for
stream persistence when you do real-time
analytics you need all the same
characteristics in the storage layer so
having the ability to pushing down your
filters accessing only the fields you
need and possibly aggregation
the streaming layer is going to make it
a lot more efficient because we spend a
lot of time just sending data over the
wire because we have the storage system
decoupled from the execution system and
so it's really important to optimize how
much data we send on the network and so
a lot of you know properties that this
system have that make a lot of sense
making sure you keep track of the
constant state of the consumer so that
we know how to recover from failure
there's this notion of snapshot that
they are pointing times we are not
consistent all the time but they are
points in time where we are consistent
the Koopalings the performance of reads
and writes so that you know rights don't
impact reads or reads on impact writes
having the ability to do parallel reads
replication data isolation all good
properties of the system and I put two
there but that's kind of what makes it a
reusable component in that stack of all
it's really important to have those good
common feature and interfaces so that we
can mix and match those components right
there are common features that make
sense in that big picture so if you look
at the blueprint all those things fit
together what does our big data
infrastructure look like today with all
those components so I started with the
simple pictures right so today we build
our apps in the cloud so people use apps
that are hosted in the cloud and we send
events like drop raindrops falling from
those clouds tracking what people are
doing how they have sub are behaving and
those droplets make streams and you have
streams of data coming and the feed into
data lakes and so that's my picture so
that you know the legs next diagram is
less dry and and so you see those r's
little water meals like processing this
data downstream so we look at the more
like architecture like diagram right so
you still have apps whatever you're
sending data to a stream persistent
layer and you know usually that would go
a very common
way of doing this is using Avro to have
a schema for those things right and then
they kind of they get they can get
processed in that stream layer here we
go
right so the data comes here and usually
you know I would say like Avro is a good
contender to have a schema that data and
you can have stream processing that
consume it and produce some derive
datasets and then eventually you archive
it in a more long-term storage and it's
going to be converted to more analytics
friendly format like park' and then you
can have a lot of batch processing also
creating derive datasets and producing
either you could have periodic
dashboards you can have interactive
analysis where people are more exploring
the data same thing you can have
real-time dashboards but you can in both
streaming and batch world you can
produce data-driven product right so you
can build recommendations you can meal
abuse detection models you can do
machine learning and use that to
feedback into the product and make
data-driven products so two main use
cases are you know dashboards
understanding how people are using the
product what works what doesn't work and
also feeding back into the product and
have a synchronous data driven products
so that's kind of the user aspects like
what analysts are using and on the other
side you noticed every time there's data
persistent I put like data API is in
front right that's where we need to pay
attention to just not use the raw
storage but have some kind of
abstraction that defines a schema
understand that every data is a schema
understand the lineage how we produce
derive datasets what version of what
data sets depend on what version of some
other data set and how to make sense of
all of this because as your company
and you have all your teams consuming
and producing data in that environment
it very quickly becomes chaos so helping
people to understand how they depend on
each other you know that's where you
have like monitoring my thing is broken
because it depends on something else and
what's happening in this right so kind
of having a schema registry like data
abstraction metadata capturing the
dependency is what the data sets what
format they're in who produces them will
consume them and understanding this on
overall global lineage graph so that's
kind of like the general blueprint like
3,000 feet up and if we look at the
future you know we talked about this
this constructed database but we're not
there yet there's some missing
components and I think as a community
and we're working on some of those I
know a lot of people are working on some
of those and we need to improve you know
we have this great open-source
composable world of a lot of components
where there are a few things we need to
improve right so still improving the
better data abstraction it was kind of
metadata repository understanding what
table exists what schema they have you
know is there statistics for
optimization understanding how they're
produced right dependencies between jobs
that are consuming producing data how
the world thing is being created there's
some like mentioned Netflix iceberg
there that's pretty good at producing
data abstraction for five based data
sets and understanding these common
pushdowns right so this whole notion of
data abstraction and having the good
properties that make it efficient you
can one make sense of it in your entire
you know you think your big data
infrastructure as being a giant database
and second kind of make it more
efficient better interoperability so
that some of the work we've done with
apache arrow in making sure things
interoperate have a goo
standard format that is efficient for
query execution a lot of different data
processing and at the same time is
standard so getting to that consensus to
have this glue that can put all those
projects together and so it's ongoing
you know it's adopted in spark there's
Python spark integration is already much
better by using Aero it's using Apache
drill it's used in many different places
the GPU based processing community is
using it a lot and so that's pretty neat
and the other thing we need to get
better at is better data governance
understanding where our user data is
being able to modify it know how we're
using it you know people store the nd
they are things GDP are how can we do it
it's all common sense we really should
be doing it which really should be
knowing what we do with our user data
and where it is and if they like it and
if we should delete it so some
prediction I think it would make a lot
of sense to have a common access layer
to all that data whether it's immutable
or mutable and have this common access
layer that implements you know schema
evolution consistent good implementation
of pushdowns
access control and enemies ation and you
know that's kind of this lower layer of
the database because you have parking by
Park is a file format and so it's really
low-level so I have a layer just on top
of that that abstract out this table
notion right and the second is kind of
like thinking of this multi tier stream
you know we always have string to batch
and converting the data for row to
columnar and this really should be one
integrating stack where we know how to
do the push downs whether first stream
or for batch and we know how come to
abstract out this whole conversion from
royalty to batch oriented so on that I'm
going to say thank you
you